Speaker 1: So the other big thing that came
from yesterday's testimony by a former aide
to a former failed President Trump's former
chief of staff, Mark Meadows, is that Donald
Trump seemed to be perfectly comfortable with and
agreeing with the idea of Hang Mike Pence. Hang
Mike Pence is a chant that now has notoriously
been associated with the January 6th protests.
There were right wingers chanting Hang Mike
Pence. They built a gallows because they
were mad that Mike Pence wasn't doing what they
believed he should be doing, which is, quote,
sending the election back to the states, something
he couldn't do. He had no power to do it. But
Trumpists believe that he did. And they started
chanting, Hang Mike Pence, hang Mike Pence.
One of the questions that has come up is why
didn't Trump do more to ensure the safety of
Mike Pence? Why didn't Trump do more to say, Hey,
guys, this is our great vice president? No, no,
no, no, no. None of this hang Mike Pence stuff.
And the reason that we now know Trump didn't do
anything about it is because he agreed with
the sentiment. Hang Mike Pence. We now have
another witness who says Trump believed that it
was reasonable to hang Mike Pence. Let's go to
yesterday's testimony from Cassidy Hutchinson.
Speaker 3: Wasn't until Mark hung up the phone,
handed it back to me. I went back
to my desk. A couple minutes later,
him and Pat came back, possibly. Eric Hershman
So I am pretty sure Eric Hershman was there.
But I'm I'm confident it was part that was there.
I remember saying something to the effect of,
Mark, we need to do something more. They're
literally calling for the vice president to
be at home. Right. And Mark had responded
something to the effect of, you heard him,
Pat. He thinks Mike deserves it. He doesn't think
they're doing anything wrong. To which Pat said
something. This is acting crazy. We need to be
doing something more. Briefly stepped into Mark's
office, and when Mark had said something with
Mark said something to the effect of he doesn't
think they're doing anything wrong. Knowing
what I had heard briefly in the dining room,
coupled with pot discussing the hanging Mike
Pence chants in the lobby of our office,
and then Mark's response. They're to
be the riders in the capital that were
chanting for the vice president to be hung.
Speaker 1: Donald Trump didn't do anything
about the Hang Mike Pence stuff because he
agreed with it. And for everybody disputing
the testimony. Listen, if Mark Meadows, instead
of defying the committee, showed up, took an oath
and answered questions, we could clear it up. We
could say, hey, you know what? Now, it's not just
Cassidy Hutchinson under oath. Now we've got Mark
Meadows. We could get Trump there under oath and
have him answer questions. Did you think it was
reasonable for Mike Pence to be hung or hanged?
But they don't want to show up. They're refusing
to show up. So to the extent that people in the
media dispute these claims show up and answer
questions under oath. Let me know your thoughts.
Find me on Twitter at David Pakman. More on
these explosive hearings after this short break.